genauso ist es patricia wir sind hier
gerade durch mehrere checkpoints
gefahren und umziehen stelle zu kommen
wo erst dann der fernsehturm attackiert
worden ich nehme euch hier einmal mit
diese freude ja was verwundert wie sie
sind hier eines der gebäude was in
direkter nähe ist und dann gehen wir
einmal in diese richtung hero und sah
wie der fernsehturm mittlerweile
aussieht man sieht gefahren nur wenige
autos und mir das ist fernsehen schon es
schneit es ist eine düstere atmosphäre
kaum licht dass ihr einsatz aber ein
glas ist gestern zum symbol des angriffs
geworden hier auf die hauptstadt der tv
tower ist nicht komplett zerstört
geschaut hast nichts wir sehen hier wie
ist aber noch man riecht sozusagen immer
noch den qualm dieses anschlags auf dem
turm man muss davon ausgehen dass
russland ist noch einmal versuchen wir
beginnen hier weiter einmal durch die
stadt und wir wollen euch zeigen wie
diese gebäude hier aus sehen wie es in
den straßen von ziert nach einem angriff
aussieht wir sehen hier
gleich ein völlig zerstörtes gebäude auf
der linken seite ich nehme euch weiter
mit hier rein auch weitere kolleginnen
hiervon film natürlich was passiert ist
hier ein völlig zerstörtes auto ich
schaue da einmal rein das passiert wenn
man hier eine rakete ab bekommt das auto
komplett zerstört auf dem boden und wenn
wir weiter gehen dann sieht man all die
beste der zerstört wo wir von dem
anschlag auf den tv- und dahinten
braucht es noch wir sind mir die
rettungskräfte dort vorstehen der rauch
des krieges
mit entschärft das sind
bedrückende bilder
die wir hier erleben in einer stadt die
ich lange kenne die ich liebe und die
jetzt angegriffen wird
was ist mit all den menschen die sich
dort in der nähe wir haben gerade ein
paar auf der straße noch gesehen paul
odernähe schilder uns muss ja wirklich
die blanke angst dort herrschen und
beschreiben uns einfach dass in diesen
minuten
jacke sind vor allem journalisten oder
soldaten wie wir weiter gehen und die
sozusagen wie wir hier sich ein bild der
lage machen es sind keine zivilisten in
der straße sondern die ich gesehen habe
ausschließlich internationale
journalisten
wir können einmal hier weiter gehen in
diese richtung
jorgos film für euch weiter
zerstört das gesamte ist hier sehen wir
ja
mitarbeiter die die reste hier um sich
dieses gebäude nähern weil wenn ihr den
rauch sieht dort im k k das ist nur zu
sagen sinnbild für das was hier passiert
ist und wenn wir da einmal auf die
straße charmatz erdgeschoss
versuchen glaube aus zu finden
und ja
arbeiten
diejenigen die vom ukrainischen
militärgeschichte
hier wird versucht sozusagen auch die
stromleitung wieder zu reparieren die
kaputt gegangen wir schauen auf die
andere seite hier auf den fernsehturm
dort im schnee liegt man ihn gestern
haben wir die bilder gesehen ja das
schon und örtlich per views schoss das
ist der turm der angegriffen wird und
angegriffen wurde und alles drumherum
ist sozusagen das
was kollateralschaden sind und wir
wissen dass mindestens mindestens vier
menschen umgekommen sind wir hier
nochmal näher dran ihren einmal durch
versuchen euch mitzunehmen
das sieht für mich aus wie ein
fitnessstudio was was es offenbar war
dort die sportgeräte noch firmen
zeitlose hier
den wir hier sports steht da drauf bei
und patricia javascript links sports an
und ist überall noch
so sieht der krieg aus vielen tier so
sieht der krieg aus ein so einfacher
satz der einem das blut gefrieren lässt
hier paul in diesen minuten du bist
dorthin gefahren heute in dieser ohnehin
schon gefährlichen stadt an die stelle
wo es gestern diese massiven
raketeneinschläge gab am tv am fernseh
tower von kiew von childers uns jetzt
live welche wucht der zerstörung dort
ausgelöst wurde gestern durch diese
massiven raketeneinschläge danke für den
tanz zeigen also hier wo ich bin und wo
ist immer noch auf das ist natürlich ein
weites stück entfernt von dem tv tower
das ist die distanz gesehen hier wenn
wir einmal durch hinter den bäumen da
schimmert der tv tower und da ging ihrer
kette reihen 1 aber du siehst
störung von guten chancen
und wir schauen wir einmal ein paar
haben einen menschen in einer freien und
wie das ganze im kümmern für mich schon
ein symbol dafür was wir in dieser stadt
forciert ein symbol dafür was putins
raketen anrichten und das hier ist erst
der anfang gewesen den vier zivilisten
ums leben gekommen
um dieses herum aber insgesamt droht ist
natürlich noch viel schlimmer zu werden
in kerth will die raketen weiter in
wohnvierteln explodieren wenn schwere
waffen wie in kharkiv eingesetzt werden
dann droht natürlich noch eine weitere
eskalation der lage
unglaubliche bilder paul die du uns
damit brings ist es völlig bizarr diese
ja dieses fitnessstudio dieses ausmaß
der zerstörung ein symbol dieses krieges
eine moderne stadt die dort zerstört
wird kannst du diese zerstörung wie weit
diese zerstörung geht irgendwie
abschätzen das sieht riesig aus
beschreiben uns noch mal was da gestern
am frühen abend passiert ist dass diese
zerstörung angerichtet hat
ja es war ein schlag der eigentlich
sozusagen dem tv zum gelten sollte also
es ging darum hier das fernsehsignal zu
zerstören das ist keine ukrainische
sendern mehr gibt wir sehen hier wird
schon gestartet jetzt mit
aufräumarbeiten also auch das ja die
leute stehen zusammen es könnte ja auch
jederzeit passieren dass sie eine
weitere rakete rein gefeiert wird aber
hier werden die aufräumarbeiten gerade
gestartet wir gehen hier noch einmal
gemeinsam durch mitnehmen dahin den
menschen in deutschland zu zeigen was
putins rakete nicht wieder auslösen was
die anregt und wenn wir weiter gehen
wenn wir das war ein supermarkt 1
auch hier braucht es völlig
wir sehen hier überall
sportgeräte zum verkauf offenbar ein
supermarkt mit sportgeräten händen sehen
wir basketbälle die noch an der wand
sind
und hier ansonsten vor allem durch den
druck der explosion der rakete die
scheiben zu bruch gegangen ansonsten
sorgte indes wenig zerstören wir überall
scherben auf der straße
paul so
sieht der krieg aus in hier